what if i don't have enough money to
follow my passion
so i got a great question for my youtube
viewers love you guys
ospreso69 who wrote in to say
what do i do if my passion is too big i
don't have enough money
for it in that case isn't it okay to
start with something else which will
give me the initial money
so here's the thing okay this is a great
question i know
one that people struggle with a lot you
know you have this vision for what you
want to do with
yourself with your career the people you
want to help the lifestyle you want to
live
and then you see where you are now and
and there's such a big gap
and you're like how do i fill that gap
how do i go and accomplish that
money is not going to be the answer for
you
okay it's not going out and doing
something that you hate to make money to
do something that you love
okay i don't want you to go launch some
kind of business
just to try to make money to find
something else the best way to do it
is to make money while you learn
everything you need to know
about that skill that you'll need to
accomplish your dream
so let me give you an example okay i
don't know what your big vision your
passion is for context but let me say
say i wanted to be a professional
speaker okay so let's look at me say i
want to be
if i wanted to be anthony robbins okay i
want to be the next anthony robbins that
was if that was my goal
and i think you know what i to do
anthony robbins i need to have money to
make cds and books and
and i need infomercials and all this is
just dollar signs and hey i don't have
that money i can't go out and do that
so how am i going to do it the answer
isn't for me to go out and try to do
something that i'm not good at
that i hate to try to make money so
you know say got an opportunity to uh
sell couches okay and say hey you can
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
selling couches
why would i go do that you know i don't
love couches i don't love selling this
stuff
i don't want to be in that business why
would i take a job
or start a business just trying to make
money because
if that's your goal your only goal is to
make money it never works right
people come to you with opportunities
hey you can make a lot of money doing
this
it never works that stuff never works
out
two options for you the better path is
one go get a job
in the field okay so if i wanted to be
the next anthony robbins
i should go work for anthony robbins if
i don't have the money to do what i need
to do
go get a job doing the thing learning
from the person who has already done
what i want to do model success
hey i you know i'm not my own
entrepreneur right now if i'm going to
work for anthony robbins but
i'm getting paid right i have money
coming to my bank account
and i'm i'm more importantly learning
the ins and outs of that business i'm
learning how he built his thing up
i'm learning how to do exactly
everything that he's doing i'm learning
how he markets i'm learning how it
connects with people i'm learning how he
creates new products
everything i'm learning i'm getting paid
to learn right as i can go to university
to do exactly what i want to do and i'm
getting paid to do it and if i make
state mistakes
i'm doing it while getting paid and it
also teach you
if this is something you want to do you
know i may go work for anthony robbins
and say hey you know what i don't want
to be the next anthony robbins anymore
i'm glad i figured that out while still
getting paid instead of jumping in and
losing my savings trying to launch it
okay so go get a job working for
somebody who can teach you about the
business
not just do something get a job or
launch your own business just trying to
make some money to support something
else
and you need to be learning how to be
better so that you can go launch your
own career
launch your own company when you go out
right i go work for tony robbins
when i'm i'm not going to be there
forever it might be six months might be
a year maybe two years but when i come
out of that
i have the connections i know who to
talk to i know how to create products
and bringing people on
i know how to do everything to build up
my business and when i launch i'm much
more likely to be successful okay that's
the first option
the second option is start smaller every
big dream that you have
can be broken down into smaller steps
you might say hey
big dream up here okay gonna cost me x
amount of dollars and it's way more than
i have
but you can notch that down see all the
little steps and say hey what can i do
to get started to bootstrap this thing
because i guarantee you there's a
there's a way to bootstrap this business
if you look at every successful famous
entrepreneur you look at how they
started
it wasn't with millions of dollars in
their pockets they started from nothing
they started with with 20 bucks
a lot of them and they bootstrap their
way up there's a way to get this thing
started
without having to spend a lot or any
money you just have to find it
and it starts with usually on the
service side
so if i wanted to be the next anthony
robbins and i see all these dollar signs
ahead of me
i could start right now i don't need
expensive gear i don't need to make a uh
cds and put on live seminars and
rent out huge hauls and create
infomercials
i don't have to do any of that stuff i
could start right now with my laptop
making these youtube videos that's a
start
that's how i started i didn't start
making videos
renting expensive gear and you know
buying all the stuff because i didn't
want to spend money until i was making
money
right now this video is off my laptop
i'm feeling a little sick today i didn't
want to get in front of the big camera
all that setup so i'm just talking from
the laptop
right there's ways to start your
business without having to spend a lot
of money
you need to find it and start building
momentum the beautiful thing is
those two things can work together you
can get a job
working for the dream company that you
want to build
right the person who you look up to the
most you go work for them
and at the same time start your own
thing on the side
start small start a service get to know
your customers
get better right you need to develop
your skills to be good at what you're
doing
that's the way to do it and that might
take you six months or a year or two
years of learning and trying
but you're making mistakes while getting
paid you're learning how to be a way
better entrepreneur and operator
and then when you finally do launch
you'll have a much higher chance of
success
and much greater chance of you hitting
that dream that you have
that's how you get started so don't go
off get some job or start some business
just trying to make money because those
things never work out
you're gonna be back here a year later
probably having less money than what you
started with
and not being happy and i don't want
that to be you
so go out and chase your dreams believe
for those of you watching i love to hear
how you've gone out and either taken a
job to learn from a mentor
or started small how you bootstrapped
your business let me know
share some examples help inspire the
people by leaving a comment underneath
if you guys like this video give it a
thumbs up below make sure to do more for
you
and click on my face there to subscribe
to the channel thank you so much
i'll see you soon